and finally new rule this Father's Day
do the right thing and go out to the
mall and get dad a polyester shirt with
ten cuff links and a nylon tie in a
plastic box he'll never wear it because
he's not the doorman at a Sicilian
whorehouse but there is a greater cause
to be considered stores are going
extinct and they're taking billions of
jobs with them Americans no longer shop
til they drop they click till they're
sick and when they want to buy a pair of
pants they don't have to put on a pair
of pants yeah so the folks who are
really suffering in this economy are the
people like the department store lady in
the lab coat who sprays you with hooker
perfume
the sales dude who says I'm not sure I
can give you that price I'll have to ask
my manager and the clerk at Victoria's
Secret who says is this a gift for
someone else
[Laughter]
how old are you now 1761 and the last
day showed up in the last two years
JCPenney has closed a hundred and
thirty-eight stores
RadioShack has closed 550 paleis shoes
400 and on and on and on but all we hear
from president man-baby is we must put
our miners back to work no the jobs
we're losing aren't in coal they're at
Kohl's
what is this fetish Trump has with coal
miners do they have a P tape on him he
said he was going to be the greatest
jobs president God ever created maybe he
could start by waddling down to forever
71 and buying a lighter shade of bronzer
in a suit that fits instead he sends out
his bizarro administrator to the EPA
Scott Pruett to announce we've had over
50,000 jobs since last quarter of coal
jobs mining jobs created in this country
oh goody now if we can just get the
asbestos and lead paint factories back
and reopen the opium dens like back when
America was great Bill Clinton's
campaign song was don't stop thinking
about tomorrow Trump should be the way
we were and the way we were was not well
mining coal isn't very good for you
neither is burning it it's the reason
why there's a billion and a half people
in China but you only see four of them
why are we working so hard to preserve
the worst job this side of deodorant
tester that's a real why why are coal
jobs so important that Scott Pruett
thinks he should lie about it because
when he says that we created 50,000 coal
jobs this quarter Wow that is something
like coal itself that he just pulled
directly out of a dark hole 50,000 this
quarter the American coal mining
industry employs 51,000 people total
there are more yoga teachers just on my
block it's worth asking why do Trump and
his fans care so much about some jobs
and not at all about others we know that
coal mining is 95% male and 95% white
but I'm sure that's not it no maybe it's
Trump's view of the economy being like a
five-year-old child he only likes coal
miners and truck drivers and
construction workers you know the kind
of jobs you see on Sesame Street
and I hate to tell you but those truck
driver jobs they're the next to go when
driverless cars become commonplace
because whether you're in retail or in
coal mining or used to work at
Blockbuster it's the same story when
someone comes along with a better idea
you get [ __ ] can't thousands of
Americans used to work as lamplighters
going around town lighting the gas
streetlights at night
then Edison came along with his light
bulb why didn't President Grant do
something to stop that because you can't
stop progress so
so say goodbye to them all now while you
still can because soon it will be a
civilization gone with the wind
and then then where will we go to eat
oversized pretzels and hot dogs on a
stick where will our teenagers go to
wander aimlessly and our elderly
population to get exercise where will
our children go at Christmas when it's
time to sit them on a pedophiles lap
without Game Stop how can hipsters trade
their old Xbox games for weed and
renowned Brookstone what will happen to
women who want to publicly moan on
vibrating chairs where will zombies
attack where will I be able to see
emotional support dogs pissing on an
artificial bush where will I be able to
get the Christian rock CDs I play to
make stragglers leave my parties
and mostly where will all the laid-off
miners go to work